in La Paz Bolivia a confusing election
is being disputed on the streets
it started peacefully opposition leader
Carlos Meza turning out the head of a
March that filled out Prado the Capitals
main Avenue tens of thousands angry
because a supposedly rapid vote count
from Sunday's election has been
repeatedly suspended
they fear that's because the government
is manipulating the figures they wanted
to reach the Electoral Tribunal to voice
their discontent but the seemingly
irresistible force met an a movable
object and it began some protesters
throwing stones curtains of tear gas
launched by police they tried to resist
ducking down lighting small fires to
disperse the gas the truth is that we've
never felt like this we thought that
yesterday was bad but today they're
really kicking our ass and the fire
smoke helps us to feel better
ballot papers proved the popular choice
of fuel it wasn't enough they're trying
to block off the center they're
advancing with tear gas so there's a lot
of nerves here for good reason she was
hit by a tear gas canister the
government's trying to calm things
asking the Organization of American
States to audit the final vote count to
instill some trust but for these people
that's coming late and fires once lit
are difficult to put out John Holman
al-jazeera LaPaz